We're going to be going back and
forth between the Objective C and
the Swift versions of GIF maker.
So go ahead and
open up both projects in Xcode.
Here we are in the Objective C project.
And we want to see how
the video camera is presented.
So let's say I didn't know
anything about this project.
But I do know that the UI
image picker controller
is what presents the video camera.
I could go over here on the left and
search image picker controller, and
I could find out where the code
to present the camera is.
And here you can see it's in this file
called UI view controller plus record.
It turns out,
we need to present the video camera
from two different UI view controllers.
So the code to present the image picker
controller is in this UI view controller
record category.
Okay.
So present video options.
That seems promising.
Let's check out this method.
Action sheet record video.
That looks like what we're looking for.
Now this record video
action calls launch camera.
Let's take a look at
the launch camera method.
Okay, here's where the image picker
controller is being created.